all right everyone today we're gonna
look at this paper challenging common
assumptions in the unsupervised learning
of decent language representations by
Francesca l'hotel oh and a bunch of
other people at Google IO ETH Zurich and
MPI folks disclaimer I know these people
and I've talked to them about this work
so just say no where I'm coming from
it's a skip paper and it's fairly sure
to explain so let's go over it the main
thing here is what's called
disentanglement so disentanglement
is kind of a property of data in
unsupervised learning or not data of
your model that you would like to have
in unsupervised learning in here
especially in generative models so what
they focus on is like Auto encoding here
and what that means is I have some data
point which could be an image let's draw
an image here and I compress this
usually into a vector and the vector has
a couple of dimensions this is a
representation of the data and from this
representation what I can do is I can
produce an image again and if I train an
auto encoder I will enforce that my
model so both of these are my model this
is called an encoder and this is called
a decoder that what they do is that the
final image then looks like the original
image this is an auto encoder basically
a compression algorithm that tries to
find representations to see that we can
reconstruct the original image again
here we go a little further in that we
use what's called a variational
colors so all of these all of these
experiments here use variants of the
variational auto encoder and what the
variational auto encoder let's skip some
here a variational auto encoder is the
same thing as an auto encoder except
it's a probabilistic framework so what
you do is here on the bottom you can see
an equation that basically is the
objective for the AE and what it does is
it says okay I have an image let's say
this my image and I use an encoder like
in an auto encoder and that gives me a
representation okay but now I don't use
this representation directly to decode
but this representation is simply the
parameters from a bunch of distributions
alright so here let's say I have four
four I want four latent factors and the
latent factors are basically the latent
variables that describe this image so
the images could be images over let's
say cats and four latent factors could
be the color of fur of the cat the size
of the cat the position in the image and
the let's say the general lighting of
how bright the image is so these could
be four latent factors that would
explain best the image and from that and
if the image could be best reconstructed
that's it
so the the four latent factors we
consider as probability distributions so
what our encoder needs your encoder
needs to produce eight numbers in this
case eight numbers why because for each
of these four distributions we want a
mean
and a standard deviation so these eight
numbers here each one or each pair of
numbers one of them is going to be the
mean and the other one is going to be
the standard deviation of a distribution
and then from these we're gonna
construct a distribution like so like
okay here's the mean here's the standard
deviation so the distribution somehow
looks like this and then we're going to
sample from this distribution so one
sample could be here one sample could be
here one sample here here of course in
the middle here we're gonna have more
samples but so the whereas the
autoencoder directly uses the encoding
to reproduce the image the variational
or encoder the nd the what the output
what the encoder produces here is simply
a parameterization for a disk for a
distribution and that distribution then
is sampled so we're gonna take one
sample here so from from each of these
so there's gonna be multiple of those
distributions because we have eight
numbers we are gonna produce four
distributions in particular so we're
gonna sample four different numbers so
we're gonna sample a new vector with
four two three four
well I didn't have eight at the
beginning but here this gives us four
numbers but these are sampled so these
are gonna be different every time even
if we feed the same image and from this
the decoder is gonna try to reproduce
the image and then again the images the
end image and the beginning I mentioned
that we forced to be close to each other
but also now since this is a
probabilistic framework we also kind of
need we need a different loss function
for the auto encoder you can simply
penalize how far the images are ends
that say l2 norm but here we have two
distinct parts to the last term so and
everything is probabilistic so let's
walk through this here the first part of
the cell we have two parts of the last
term and here in particular Q is you can
see here it takes as an is it is the
distribution of Z conditioned on X and Z
will always be related representation of
the of the data and X will be the the
data itself the data point so Q will
take the data point and produce Z and
the Z specifically here what's meant is
this this thing here this is Z whereas
this is this is X and this is also well
this is X tilde or something whatever is
produced by the decoder so basically
what we're gonna do is we're gonna
punish the KL distance which is a
probabilistic a distance measure we're
gonna measure the distance between the
distribution of Z under X um with the
prior over Z so P of Z here this here is
the prior distribution over Z and the
prior distribution in vis is often to be
taken as a Gaussian so we'll say all
right so they are our kind of default
assumption on the Z variables is that
they're they're gaussians
and we're gonna force basically and of
course the encoder to come up with
encoding generally over the data set
that are thousands that are conformal to
our prior so here we say specific prior
TZ I didn't mean to cross that up right
so this second term enforces the the
encoder to produce things that are
Gaussian and specifically with our if
our prior is let's say 0 0 mean unit
variance gal since it's gonna enforce
that the first term here is different
the first term makes the image that has
been input to the variational or encoder
in the image that has been output close
together again this is a probabilistic
loss so what we're gonna do here is
we're gonna take expectations so the KO
distance is also an expectation by the
way we're gonna take expectations over
px which is the distribution of the data
and also over q and q is again our
encoding mechanism and we're simply
going to punish T or we're gonna here
maximize the the log probability which
is equivalent to minimizing the negative
log likelihood which you might be
familiar with of the data given the Z
variables so um and this is an
expectation over Q given X so what that
means is basically we want t the
probability of this original data point
we want here we output X tilde we
we want this to be close to X here so
what we can say is we want the
probability that our model outputs X
which has been the original input right
given this particular Z that it produced
to be high as an expectation of Q of Z
given X so it's a bit cryptic but it
means here I input X into Q I get out Z
and when I have the Z what I produce
here is what I produce the likelihood
that X the original image seen either
same is produced should be high so
that's a variational autoencoders I
simply encourage the latent
representations to be close to my prior
which softened Gaussian and I encourage
the output to be similar to the input
which I do by encouraging the likelihood
that the output is the input all right
so cool so what's that have to do with
this entanglement
this entanglement is properly that now I
would like to have in my model which is
that these these things here or we can
also focus on these things here however
you want to view it or these things here
these latent things that my encoder
output somehow give me information about
the data in a way that's disentangled
what that means is I vote for it
I've made an example this already
disentangled where I said let's let's
say we have images of a cat of cats and
the fur color is going to be one
variable and the color of the eyes of
the cat is going to be another one and
the position in the image is gonna be
another one so these are all fairly
independent right
so I if I change some Layton factor I
can change them pretty much
independently so here this could be the
third color I can change it pretty much
independently and cat will just have a
different fur and so on what would be
non disentangle representations would be
um let's say one encodes the fur of the
cat and the other one encodes the
species of cat because these are these
are highly let's say entangled so the
fur color is highly dependent on what
species the cat is and it's not really
so they kind of you can you can imagine
it as these things being correlated but
it's slightly different and there are
there's not an agreement on what this
entanglement means really we just kind
of imagine data is somehow entangled and
we want to kind of pull out these
disentangle factors so what they focus
on here and the easiest the easiest
measure here is the following I might
want to have some space alright so the
easiest measure of this entanglement
that is come up with here is the
following it's an assumption the
assumption is let's say there's data X
right we'll call it random error and we
know we know we assume that this data is
generated by a bunch of latent variables
Z 1 Z 2 Z 3 which are independent which
means that and the technical thing for
this is that the P of Z which is all of
them can be factorized into P of Z I so
they are independent and these kind of
determine independently the data X
now what does the disentanglement
when my model has produced a disentangle
representation means I now have a model
some model and which is going to give me
a representation of X and the
representation as we saw before could be
these things here that's the that
representation is specifically what
these people do is they say okay the
mean of the distribution that my encoder
gives me that's the representation of X
alright so this gives you a
representation of X from which you then
might want to you know reconstruct X
over here X but so the important thing
is when is the representation
disentangled the representation astiz
entangled in the easiest sense if the
following holds when I change when I
change Z I so I introduce a delta to Zi
to any of these three that means that in
the representation of X which which is
gonna say so if there's three dimensions
of Z we just assume kind of we know that
and we also make the representation
three dimensional then exactly one
factor in this is going to change so if
I change one factor of the true
underlying distribution which is
independently which all the latent
factors are independent then only one
factor in my representation changes so
if that's the case then kind of I can be
fairly sure that I've captured the true
latent structure of the data right if
one if if one of the
of the if I change one of the the Z here
let's say I change Z 3 and only then R 3
so I change the 3 let's say I've access
to the true underlying distribution I
asked the the world ask the world to
give me a picture of a cat that where
the fur color is different and then I
put it I get a data point and then I put
it through malleable I get a
representation and only from the cat
that I had before only one of the
factors of my representation changes
then I call it is entangle then it can
be fairly sure ok my representation this
dimension of my representation captures
the fur color independently of the other
factors all right so that's this
entanglement and you know this it
requires actually access here to the
true distribution of how the data is
generated by the world so this is
something you generally don't have but
it's a technical notion so you can you
can certainly postulate it and it's it
it's a nice framework and this paper
basically proves that generally learning
this integral representation in that way
is impossible if you don't have some if
you don't make some assumption some a
priori assumptions on your data and your
model so this is a theorem here and we
see here P is any generative model which
admits this factorization right is that
that's what we talked about the true
underlying generative process is has is
independent in so in its constituents
that means there's a bunch of latent
variables they independently from each
other produce a data point right X is
the date observations then there exists
an infinite family of by ejected
Auctions all right search that ha this
and this and this and this okay what
that means is so this thing here
basically just means that the the
distributions agree so that the overall
distributions there that say that it's
not exactly that but the posterior
distributions let's say the data looks
the same right that what comes out of
the process looks the same so there is
there is functions that transform the
latent distribution into some other
distribution but they look the same in
cumulatively alright and then this part
here means you'll see the derivative of
F I of U with respect to some UJ which
you'll notice I and J are different and
if this means that they're basically the
dimensions error and tangled I means
that if I take the derivative of one
entry in the in the F in the function
output and I derive it by another entry
then I get a nonzero derivative which
means that this UJ influences fi which
basically means that I can produce I can
take the Z I can transform it in slz is
independent so it means the I of
dimension has no influence on where J
eighth dimension of the of the output
and I can transform it into something
where that's no longer the case where
the I attend the jus dimension very much
kind of are entangled are covariate so
this
I can take the Z that that's kind of
everything is independent I can
transform it into something where
everything is dependent and they give it
a nice example here so they say let's
say we have gal scenes in two dimensions
so we have one Gauss in here and let me
see if I can draw this on Gus and here
right in two dimensions they're
completely independent what you'll find
is that the kind of distribution overall
has ISIL lines like this right it gives
you kind of a hump in the middle two
dimensionally you can maybe imagine like
a bit of a mountain in the middle all
right so this is what you this is the
kind of output distribution if you if
you don't know about the underlying
factories you simply see the cumulative
distribution which be the big key here
all right
now we transform this into with F and F
is simply a rotation by 45 degrees right
so two new axis this and that and again
our two gaussians are going to be
transformed of these right so these are
not these are not disentangled anymore
well in the in the notion I can't say it
like this but this is easiest to say so
these are these are kind of now that is
rotated in terms of the original
coordinate system which would go like
this
these very much depend on each other
right jus dimension dimension depend on
each other because if I sample from one
of the gaussians I need now basically
two coordinates to describe where it is
or yeah I get one isn't just so if I
sample from one Gaussian and I change I
need both the coordinates but the
cumulative distribution or D it's still
going to look exactly the same so it's
again a hum so it's basically an
isometric hump in every direction
if I rotate that the it looks exactly
the same
this is the P here
but now the iof dimensional jf dimension
very much influence each other and yeah
interestingly if you now look at this
entanglement if I just have if if I now
produce data X here X 1 and here I
produce data X 2 and both go through my
model and give me our representation of
X 1 and the representation of X 2 I have
without seeing the underlying structure
I have no idea which one of those two it
comes from and thereby I have zero
chance basically cell luck lucky guess
which one it comes from and there's an
infinite family so I will never find the
true underlying distribution here and
thereby I will never I will never be
able to satisfy this property that if
one of the Z changes then only one of
the factors of my representation will
change because if I say oh well
obviously this is the case then I'm
going to make a different model and if I
say well this is the case I'm going to
make a different model I don't know
which one this off to choose one and it
could be the other one so I'm bound to
be wrong in this case 50% of the time
but if it's an infinite family I'm bound
to be wrong every time basically so
that's what the theorem basically says I
can't decide on the true underlying
distribution there's an infinite family
that transforms it into it transforms
every distribution into some other
distribution that has basically complete
opposite properties of entanglement and
to choose one and I will never choose
the right one because I'm not that lucky
and thereby I can't do representation
learning that's disentangled all right
so that's the main claim of the paper
and
there is a lot of experiments here so
what the paper also does is they do some
data sets and they test a lot of a lot
of our architectures basically they say
just because it's theoretically
impossible it's not impractical because
we can actually make these underlying
assumptions like we can make some
assumptions on the data in there and
then we kind of can attempt to do this
entanglement learning so they do these
data sets and they test different VA EES
architectures on it and they basically
establish where more work should go so
that's that's kind of the rest of the
paper I encourage you to look at the
rest of the paper I just wanted to give
a quick introduction to the AES and to
disentanglement just tangled
representation learning
I wasn't technically correct in every
detail but I hope that it's enough and
have fun